[Music]  5 26 on your wednesday morning of your  question about the ongoing work at the  speedway bowl technically known as the  i-15 north corridor project  andrew wants to know when will range  road be done merging onto the 215 and 15  south  it's getting bad  and rough  well andrew it has been a bumpy ride in  that whole area they're building all  those new flyover bridges and ramps  that'll eventually make it a lot  smoother and easier connecting the 15 in  the northern 215 beltway original  timeline from the nevada department of  transportation was for everything to be  wrapped up there by the end of this year  but that was before the pandemic so i'll  be checking with the folks at ndot see  if they have any updates thanks for  writing buckle up drive carefully please  put down that phone something driving  you crazy email me traffic 8  8newsnow.com